CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR FALSE
STATEMENTS.
SO THIS GETS REAL SERIOUS REAL
FAST.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE MAN
HIMSELF, JONATHAN TURLEY, GEORGE
WASHINGTON, CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
PROFESSOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
JONATHAN, GETS TO SEE YOU.
SO PROFESSOR.
>> THANKS.
>> EXPOUND UPON THAT POINT.
WHY MIGHT THIS GET WORSE FOR JOE
BIDEN IN THE END?
>> WELL, THERE WAS A CURIOUS
STATEMENT OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT THIS INFORMATION IS
PERSONAL BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PERSONAL RESIDENCE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT DOG WON'T HUNT.
YOU REALLY DON'T HAVE AN
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS NOW A
PURELY PERSONAL RESIDENCE WHEN
YOU'VE STORED HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THERE.
SO THIS IS AT BEST AN
INVESTIGATOR SCENE.
BUT YOU CAN'T SAY JUST BECAUSE
IT'S A PRIVATE RESIDENCE THAT
CONGRESS HAS NO RIGHT TO FIND
OUT WHO HAD ACCESS TO AN AREA
THAT MAY HAVE COMPROMISED
NATIONAL SECURITY.
SO ONCE THAT WIRE WAS TRIPPED,
BY FINDING THOSE DOCUMENTS IN
THE GARAGE, CONGRESS CLEARLY HAS
AN OVERSIGHT INTEREST IN KNOWING
WHO WAS IN THAT HOUSE AND
WHETHER THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
COMPROMISING OF NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION.
NOW, IF THEY DON'T HAVE A LOG,
THEN CONGRESS IS ALLOWED TO
PURSUE OTHER MEANS TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
THEY CAN SEEK TO INTERVIEW
FAMILY AND STAFF.
THOSE INTERVIEWS WILL OCCUR
UNDER THE PENALTY OF PERJURY OR
MAKING FALSE STATEMENTS TO
CONGRESS.
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE TO THE
ABILITY OF CONGRESS TO PURSUE
THIS INFORMATION.
>> CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
DEFENSES THROWN OUT.
JOE BIDEN SAID, I TAKE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS SERIOUSLY,
OTHERS HAVE SAID IT WAS A
MISTAKE THAT JOE BIDEN HAD THE
DOCUMENTS AT HIS RESIDENCE OR
BIDEN IS COOPERATING WITH THE
DOJ.
DO ANY OF THOSE DEFENSES
ACTUALLY WORK IN THIS POTENTIAL
CRIME?
>> WELL, THE INADVERTENT DEFENSE
CRUMBLES FAIRLY QUICKLY AFTER IT
WAS FIRST RAISED.
IT'S HARD TO MAKE AN INADVERTENT
DEFENSE WHEN YOU HAVE DOCUMENTS
THAT PRESUMABLY WERE TAKEN
AROUND 2017 WHEN HE LEFT OFFICE
AS VICE PRESIDENT.
AND THEN APPEARED TO BE DIVIDED
AND DISTRIBUTED AT DIFFERENT
SPOTS.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY WOULD YOU
HAVE THAT DIVISION UNLESS THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE BEING USED FOR
SOME PURPOSE?
THE PURPOSE COULD BE ONE OF A
NUMBER OF THINGS BUT THE MOST
OBVIOUS WOULD BE THE USE -- TO
BE USED ON THE BOOK, THAT THE
THEN VICE PRESIDENT WAS WORKING
ON, WHICH INCLUDED SUBJECTS LIKE
UKRAINE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW
THAT.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER QUESTIONS
RAISED BY THE MOST RECENT
DISCLOSURES.
YOU KNOW, THE LAST STATEMENT WAS
THAT VARIOUS DOCUMENTS WERE
MISSED IN THE SEARCH OF THE
RESIDENCE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS REALLY
PERPLEXING BECAUSE I'VE WORKED
WITH CLASSIFIED MATERIAL FOR
OVER THREE DECADES.
THEY ARE USUALLY HELD IN A
FOLDER THAT HAS A VERY
PRONOUNCED BORDER.
USUALLY RED OR YELLOW OR
STRIPED, AND THEN ACROSS THE
FRONT IS, IN BOLD LETTERS, A
CLASSIFICATION.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO MISS.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING THROUGH A
PILE.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHETHER SOME
OF THESE DOCUMENTS WERE NOT IN
THEIR FOLDERS.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, IT GETS EVEN
MORE SERIOUS BECAUSE IT WOULD
MEAN THAT SOMEONE HAD TO REMOVE
A DOCUMENT FROM A FOLDER.
THAT PERSON CLEARLY THEN KNEW
THAT THERE WERE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THERE, AND THAT THEY
WERE INTERACTING WITH THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT.
ALL OF THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE GOT
TO BE ANSWERED.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHO HAD ACCESS
TO THE DOCUMENTS AND WHETHER
THEY HAD CLEARANCE OR NOT.
LET ME GET TO THIS, SOME IN
WASHINGTON THINK THIS
INVESTIGATION IS A COMPLETELY
OPEN AND ENDED SHUT CASE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS ISN'T A PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX INVESTIGATION.
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE NOW, AN
OFFERS SPACE, TWO RESIDENCES TO
GO OUT THERE, FIGURE OUT IF ALL
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION HAS
BEEN RECOVERED, WHO THE PEOPLE
WERE WHO HAD ACCESS TO IT, ALL
THE CIRCUMSTANCES BY WHICH IT
CAME TO BE PLACED THERE,
SHOULDN'T TAKE A LOT OF TIME.
>> JONATHAN PETER IS BACK AND HE
DOESN'T THINK IT'S THAT COMPLEX
OF AN INVESTIGATION BUT PROBABLY
NOT FOR THE REASONS HE THINKS.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> I FIND IT QUITE REMARKABLE
THAT EVERYONE CAME OUT AND SAID,
LOOK THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
ANYTHING OTHER THAN INADVERTENCE
HERE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE AT ALL.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS REFUSED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE EVIDENCE WE HAVE SEEMS TO GO
AGAINST INADVERTENT, WHEN YOU
REALLY DON'T KNOW, BUT WHAT'S
REALLY ASTONISHING IS HOW ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING FORTH
SAYING, LOOK, THE RECORD AS IT
STANDS SHOWS INADVERTENCE.
WHAT RECORD?
YOU HAVE AT MOST, YOU HAVE A
GROUP OF DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
DIVIDED FOR SOME REASON, AND
SENT TO DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
IF THE PRESIDENT INTERACTED WITH
THOSE DOCUMENTS, THEN HE
SHATTERS HIS DEFENSE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT MAKES THESE
RECENT STATEMENTS LOOK LIKE AN
EFFORT TO DECEIVE THE PUBLIC AND
THE F.B.I.
NOW, DO WE KNOW ANY OF THAT?
NO, BUT THE PRONOUNCEMENT THAT
THERE IS NOTHING TO SEE HERE IS
ODD BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN
VIRTUALLY ANYTHING A